I kind of like y'all there a little bit
I think teaches them some values yeah
get these kids to work yeah tell I got
to start getting some Cobalt honestly if
if anyone could benefit from child labor
it's American Kids
[Music]
okay so Apple finally decided to do
something about the horrifying
conditions of cobalt mining in Africa do
you know about that yes yes I do
so every single iPhone that you're using
has got a battery in it that every micro
chip yeah it's not just Apple it's
everything yeah pretty much everything
yeah you got to have Cobalt and how do
you get cobalt you gotta mine for it but
where do you do that Africa and who's
doing it kids yeah oh and a lot of poor
people it's like 20 000 people in this
pit yeah everyone's covered in like mud
and they're just hand mining it holy
[__] so that's just one example so that
when it when we see scenes like that in
America it's usually Coachella or like a
massive yeah but out there they're
working it's cold it's work you know
Cobalt it's not it's not burning man
it's actual burning men and children
yeah so the crazy thing is they do they
do this like weird thing allegedly with
to skirt around the international law
where like oh we can't employ actual
children to mind this Cobalt so we'll
just leave the mind there if some kids
happen to want to go look for themselves
and they want to sell it to us as a free
Trader or a was it like a a contractor
yeah they're on a 1099 yeah yeah so
they'll just like all these people are
just looking for whatever Cobalt they
can find and they'll send kids into the
smallest holes because none of these
guys are mining with the right equipment
yeah nobody is using any safety standard
someone's just gonna make a hole and ask
a kid to crawl through it and get it
because these people literally don't
have a choice honestly like they were
saying like it's either fine Cobalt that
day or you don't eat damn it's like that
level of poverty that's the that's where
I wanted to play Devil's Advocate where
like I think from our lens it sucks when
kids have to work but like let's say if
an adult works and they get cobalt they
can eat but it takes two people to get
cobalt so they can have two meals
another person just so happens to be a
kid and if we don't let kids do that in
their specific economy isn't uh that us
taking food away from the kid yeah but
the the outrage behind this is that
apple had been denying that this was
even happening at all and then if Apple
knows
then they're like hey you should be
ethically sourcing your Cobalt right
instead of but then there's also the
other part of it is like what if there
was no like what if these people were
starving in in general right and then
now there's industry for them to work so
now they can get food so like who knows
I don't know the origin story well it's
just like what we saw with those guys
um I forgot if it was in Thailand where
they had monkeys that they trained to
get the Coconuts for them and then uh
you know people that well all the way
the [__] over here were like no you
can't do that because that's cruel but
then they're like I'm not gonna just
stop doing this and not have any income
in my Village and then the monkeys were
like I am hungry yeah are you gonna pay
for my meals are you gonna give me food
it is a tough call because like who are
you from the first world to tell
somebody over there but stop doing that
thing Americans love doing that though
right like we love doing that no we get
off on that we love it because it's like
virtue signaling like well I'm not gonna
have an iPhone and I don't know the
industry enough to where it's like do
the mining companies all like have their
own minds and then they illegally buy
more because they can't meet demand and
then so they're buying it from like so
like let's say like Hey we're buying it
from author authorized dealers we don't
know where it's coming from right and
then the authorized dealers like yeah
that's coming from our mind but then
they're the Shady ones that are also
buying the extra stock from these
illegal mines right like there's so many
probably new there's so much Nuance
probably to it it's like how do we know
like this one guy tracked um a luxury
Gene company in Europe
and he tracked it all the way to North
Korean slave camps because he was like
what they were doing is and that the
company didn't know and then everyone's
like yeah sure you didn't know but I'm
like I can see how people cannot know
because like let's say you're going to a
warehouse in China and this China you
have a contract with to making your
jeans but they have a contract with
North Korea yeah to manufacture you're
not privy no so you don't know so you
think you're buying it so you're like
hey I'm gonna send my denim
to this Factory so this Factory gets it
and it goes your job is to patch it up
put our logo whatever and then they're
like well it's cheaper for us to put
this in a container put it to North
Korea and then they package it whatever
and this is done illegally because
they're not supposed to buy trade go
through that way and then they just send
it there they send the uh train back and
it's already done and then so it's at
the warehouse so it's like
there's also a lot of they linked a lot
of Major Brands in the US too that does
it this way unknowingly because it's
going through China first or it might be
going through other Asian countries that
don't have that issue with North Korea
and for protection of the deal itself
they're not wanting to tell them what's
really going on either yeah no one's
asking questions really can't well we
can't work with you guys because you
just you just messed up and told us what
are you really getting and stuff that's
the same deal with tires how they Source
the rubber for that it's like very
extremely poor people making this rubber
like all the way in Southeast Asia by
the time it gets here it's marked up
insanely and what they make does not
reflect what we sell it for here but
both sides know nothing of the other or
they act like they don't you know what I
mean that's crazy because it's so far
removed in this case their solution now
Apple says okay here's what we're gonna
do
and it does kind of [__] these people
over they're gonna say all right for
2025 whatever
every iPhone will be made from an old
iPhone that already exists so we're not
going to get any more oh now they don't
make money so they don't have an economy
anymore exactly so you just like cut out
this entire bunch of people that maybe
this was all they could do and it wasn't
pretty yeah but maybe there they would
rather do this than whatever other thing
right is offering so hard right yeah who
knows it's like lesser of two evils like
they're all bad situations but you know
again in a country like this where
there's probably very few options and
you've just taken another one away
because of you know something not being
up to American Standard yeah it's an
iffy situation yeah but then it's like
also
um we're so detached from the source of
things right like the force of the
source of meat that we eat the Plastics
that we get everything that builds this
right yeah so like I think like people
become shocked when they see the whole
um the truth the source and the whole
like process Line supply chain supply
chain because like
the truth is
slavery still exists but in a different
form but like huge like economic slavery
and all the where the oil comes from all
this stuff right and I'm like
how stupid can you be but then at the
same time I'm like well you don't most
people don't take the extra time to go
from one point to another point to
another point to a month and then you go
oh so this is where it comes from
and then the Nuance of like well
yeah it's like they're already poor so
now there's opportunity but then it's
like at the same time it's exploitative
still yeah it's hard even charity
because there's like hey we come to
these countries and we give them a ton
of shoes and clothes right and then all
the local places that were providing
shoes and clothes or go out of business
because of TOMS
[__] Toms there was this one story
about like this church that really
wanted to there was like a food shortage
in this country this is like in Africa
or something and then they're like what
we're gonna do is just bring a ton of
eggs because like it was just a campaign
like let's give them eggs right so then
they would send over eggs or they would
buy local all the local eggs whatever
and what it ended up doing was it
destroyed like the egg industry in a
matter of a year of that country because
of the yeah because they flooded the
market with eggs
or they bought up all the supply just
gave it to the hungry and then so like
temporarily the businesses were doing
well because they're like they're buying
it but then they're like well Americans
are going to buy it I'm gonna jack up
the price
oh and then they're getting it and then
the people getting it for free and all
this stuff and then it's like it just
ruins the economy by doing it this way
so it's like you can't just flood it
with free clothes now what are people
gonna do you can't teach a man to fish
they can't build their own industry
because they're just getting free
t-shirts so what are yeah what are they
gonna do they can't sell their own
clothes anymore so it's like so crazy
that like the effects are sometimes
unpredictable like what happened when I
think I feel like it was a bill in
Melinda Gates Foundation donated a ton
of mosquito Nets somewhere in Africa or
Somali or something and what they did
was they took those Miss units and they
turned them into fishing nets and they
overfished oh wow and it ruined the uh
the fish population yeah and they didn't
have enough the next season
so then they were like well now you
can't give them mosquito Nets because
they're going to turn them into fishing
nets and they stop doing that and now
they're all getting [__] [__] and
[__] yeah and then malaria malaria
spreads and then that becomes a problem
for the bordering Nations right and it's
like what a crazy like ecosystem yeah
yeah yeah or like well let's say we do
it the right way right where everyone
um they're unionized they get their job
they they mine the Cobalt right let's
say the Dream the Dream Center right
yeah what if now this is twenty thousand
dollars yeah
see right now so it's like now what do
we do we gotta get those kids back in
there
yeah yeah no sure yeah
can I get a Galaxy you'll save me with
chocolate too I think there's like a lot
of like cocoa Farms or something that
was it's like basically all child labor
so all the chocolate we eat well they
know what good chocolate tastes like
yeah kids love chocolate they know
smoke us for 40 years making chocolate
you can't even taste that you know what
they say as you get older your taste
buds go away so what's better kids know
like everything we enjoy is like either
tied to like some sort of child slavery
or like violence or something you know
what I mean like oil and stuff it's tied
to water you know everything is tied to
something negative it's like it's almost
like you can't really Escape it so what
do you really do there's there's a
really strange uh situation too when a
region has an element or a mineral that
they have no use for but you do that's
kind of like they can't do anything with
the Cobalt there like what are they
gonna do yeah I wish there's like a way
or like someone that because like you
know the Middle East they're so balling
because they got oil everyone needs oil
so if somehow they can do that where
they're like okay cool everyone needs
Cobalt and they can build like an Empire
off of that yeah they still need to find
some sort of Leverage yeah yeah
it's the exploitation part of it because
like let's say you're you're like Stone
Age Technology right and then you know
these like current day Nations need oil
but then you don't know how to control
your own country yet because you're
destabilized then it's like well you
well it's better to I guess like you
guys come in and run it yeah yeah yeah
yeah I think it becomes a shady deal
it's a shame and then they no longer
have control of their own land yep and
you know what else is scary too is if
we're trying to be a superpower and
we're like okay you know what we'll pull
our businesses out of cobalt that area
or whatever China has been like this the
whole time yeah oh [__] see you later
right and they come in and they'll do
and who knows yeah because they don't
give a [__] they don't give a [__] who
knows if they're gonna happen
you're breaking my bones and then now
they're the ones mining all the Cobalts
see you later sucker
yeah you're like you know what I mean
because if it's a destabilized part it's
like all the superpowers are fighting
for that yeah absolutely damn that's
scary and that's kind of happening
before our eyes right now with a lot of
parts of Africa yeah it's like a war
between not Africa it's like other
people are trying to Jack Africa isn't
it isn't it crazy how like uh people
that don't see that every day but
they're like oh but these people
shouldn't be you know working these kids
and we agree with that but it's like if
you take that away then this happens and
then if you take that away
but some of those people are the same
people that are like we should it should
be fair and then they see like all their
prices at Walmart's getting high and
they're like what the [__] yeah it's
like well you gotta pay for it like yeah
that's how it works yeah and I feel like
those kids out there in Africa I think
they're way stronger than our American
Kids dude hell yeah they'll be okay our
kids you put our kids to work nothing's
gonna get done no Cobalt's gonna get
money they suck at the fair when they're
doing the panning for gold yeah
dude you put American kids in the Sun
for like 20 minutes you're like oh
forget I saw this one viral video of
this of this this African kid he's in
the Sudan and he was like working in a
mine and he's covered in sand uh-huh
there's a cow or like a horse or
something
he walks under the like the cow like
nothing like it's a [__] shower and
he starts showering in the urine of of
the it's sterile yeah no it's fine but
it's like to him he's like yeah this is
normal but like you show this to any
American out here they're gonna be like
oh my God we have to save them but it's
like yeah okay but they've been doing
that for a thousand years that's how
that's how they operate like they're
different breeds that's the trouble with
first word first world values
encroaching on like third world issues
that's the hard part but the thing is it
wasn't that long ago that families here
were Mining and [__] in Europe they
were Mining and two years ago yeah
in 19 [__] 20 there was like child
labor yeah no yeah you see all those
black and white pictures of dusty ass
white kids and yeah and coal mines and
[__] but also the life expectancy was
also kind of low I kind of liked y'all
there a little bit I think it teaches
them some values yeah get these kids to
work yeah tell taika to start getting
some Cobalt honestly if if anyone could
benefit from child labor it's American
Kids
is before he does his course he has to
put my shoes on
he puts you
puts you to do his chores like yeah he
just I just like because a lot of his
chores are outside I put this away uh
feed the dog fill up the dog a lot of
the outside stuff and so before he goes
outside he always goes and puts my shoes
on yeah
I would do that with my Dad's shoes as a
kid I think this is a kid thing I like
the idea if him mocking you like duh
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right